hey guys it's Wednesday I'm Dan and I'm
ed and it's time for gamespot news you
were way more into this than I am
[Music]
first up if you tuned into the
Australian leg about 72 hour extra life
livestream you might have seen this
place in always sacrifice hell-blade
whatever the way that enslaves anyway
the development ninja theory has
released a new dev diary on hell-blade
and revealed some pretty interesting
stats about the game help light is
probably most famous for its permadeath
saver raising feature that caused a
minor furor when it was released if the
main character sin or dies enough times
the game want players that her adventure
will come to an end and all progress
will be lost
it seems this hasn't deterred play as
though as hell BladeCenter with
sacrifice has now sold 500,000 units in
three months which makes the game
profitable the game was only sold
digitally on ps4 and PC and apparently
the sales are split almost evenly on
both platforms ninja theory are using
their new financial freedom to broaden
the game's grassroots marketing campaign
to hopefully showcase the title to a
wider gaming audience
Paul blade some newest sacrifice is
available on ps4 on PC and is one of the
more important games of this here so do
check it out if you can my personal
number 3 game of the year Wolfenstein 2
the new Colossus now has a pre demo you
should jump on and immediately if you
haven't already because it is a very
good game that's true you can grab the
trial version of this year's best story
driven first-person shooter on ps4 PC
and Xbox one the trial gives you access
to the game's first level with all
progress carrying over to the ball game
if you end up buying it and why wouldn't
you there's not to killing a
guilt-ridden protagonist and some of the
most cinematic cutscenes in video games
Wolfenstein 2 is also seeing a pretty
sweet price drop as part of Black Friday
those of you in the u.s. can pick up the
physical addition from Best Buy or Game
Stop for 25 bucks which is more than 50%
off well the matrix version of the game
is being digitally distributed on your
platform of choice for $30
guess what video game fans the Star Wars
Luke box saga continues to rage oh and
it certainly does the French authorities
has been investigating it the Belgian
authorities have been investigating it
and now there's investigations that come
in stateside well kind of US politicians
representing the state of Hawaii have
publicly condemned the use of loot boxes
in battlefront - in a press conference
describing it as a predatory practice
that has the potential to take advantage
of vulnerable people
state representative Chris Lee said he
was taking action to quote ensure future
protections for
kids youth and everyone else he calls
battlefront to a star wars-themed
online casino designed to lure kids into
spending money before emphasizing no
joke it's a trap if you're somehow not
clued up on this drama here's a
refresher battlefront to use progression
system incorporates star cards that have
a very tangible impact on how well we
perform in online matches these are
obtained in a completely random fashion
by loot boxes purchased with in-game
credits or real-world money the latter
of which EA disabled in response to the
backlash Lee said this is something we
need to address to ensure the
particularly kids who are underage who
are not psychologically and emotionally
mature enough to gamble which is why
gambling is prohibited under 21 are
protected from being trapped into these
cycles which have compelled many folks
to spend thousands of dollars in gaming
fees online the Democratic rep is
looking to push us legislation that
would prohibit the sale of certain kinds
of games to underage individuals as well
as prohibiting the use of loot box
mechanics and games as a whole Lee says
he's been talking with a number of other
state reps and wants to address these
issues before they become the norm
that's everything we have for you today
and tomorrow is Thanksgiving in the US
and if you want to get some sweet deals
on Black Friday where would I go Edmond
wheat Black Friday deals on gang spot
calm we have like thousand articles it
seems on all the best deals you can get
on video games on where it's Sara
so do it doing that yeah we'll see you
guys tomorrow and Jess should be back or
if not it'll just be a hostess
there was no exciting conclusion about a
good
you